i want to know what the modern bonnie
and clyde look like this married new
york couple has been caught in an
alleged 4.5 billion dollar crypto
laundering scheme
two individuals were arrested for an
alleged conspiracy to launder
cryptocurrency that was stolen during
the 2016 hack of bitfinex a virtual
currency exchange presently valued at
approximately 4.5 billion
3.6 billion in bitcoin have also been
recovered
that's the department's largest
financial seizure ever
him
ilya dutch liechtenstein
a technology entrepreneur investor and
founder of the blockchain startup end
pass
he's also a dual russian u.s citizen
her
heather morgan
self-declared crocodile of wall street
wraps under the alto ego razil khan
[Music]
morgan's website does a better job in
describing her
no one knows for sure where this rap is
from could be the north african desert
the jungles of vietnam or another
universe all that matters is she's here
to stick up for misfits and underdogs
everywhere
plus she's a former forbes contributor
here's her most recent bio on their
website
an international economist serial
entrepreneur and investor in b2b
software companies
when she's not reverse engineering black
markets to think of better ways to
combat fraud and cyber cybercrime she
enjoys wrapping and designing streetwear
fashion
if convicted the couple's facing up to
25 years in prison
dutch and razzlecon allegedly spent some
of the stolen money on gold nfts and a
500 walmart gift card
bitcoin didn't see that coming